everyone says cars - sucks it does let's
talk about it uh well you all know what
I follow the first cars film and heck
even people like the first film know
that they can't like the second one
because good god why would anyone make a
sequel to this one I mean it's just the
stupidest goddamn concept and yet they
still made us sick my point is that if
you thought the first film didn't have
much of a premise this one is definitely
running on fumes the story or as best I
can follow it's surprisingly kind of
complicated has to deal with a secret
agent of cars that's right it's a spy
car flick there's some sort of evil
corporation that wants to keep cars
running on gasoline instead of some sort
of other new energy safe fuel that's
right so it's an environmentally safe
spy car the tow truck played by Larry
the Cable Guy gets confused for a spy so
he has to go in and try to figure out
what this evil corporation is up to they
find out that the corporation is raking
races that's right to fool people into
still using gasoline instead of the
energy safe stuff yeah remember how he
said in wall-e they had sort of a subtle
environmental message and then they
hammered it on the head just a little
too much this is a jackhammer on
the head even Captain Planet is coming
in saying this is not subtle enough but
anyway the tow truck keeps getting by
fooling the other people into thinking
he's a superspy even if he's not
entirely aware of it himself they think
it's all just a show that he's just
playing stupid to convince the enemy
that he really is stupid when in
actuality he really is stupid a cute
concept but yeah I seen this a few times
before to all the other cars like Owen
Wilson and I don't know whoever the hell
else was in the other film doesn't seem
to make much of an appearance think of
looking for the tow truck but it's only
a once in awhile cameo you're basically
watching Larry the Cable Guy and yeah if
you say that you can see at least one of
the major problems of this film the
other is that you don't care this is a
dumb idea the whole idea of cars was a
dumb idea but now you're turning into a
spy flick what
first won't even have to do it spies it
didn't where is this coming from
the big reveal at the end about who the
bad guy is is not really surprising and
honestly I kind of forgot who that
character was so it wasn't even that big
of a hint and the rest of the film is
mostly just been asking the same
questions you asked in the first one
like how do cars sit down do they sit
down do they stand up how do the toilets
work actually I take it back there's a
funny scene with a Japanese toilet that
made me laugh why is it the only jokes
that make me laugh in these movies are
the toilet jokes that's not a good sign
and again I can't think of anything
horrible for kids not to watch um is
there anything really offensive in it or
any bad morals not really but it's just
stupid it's a stupid idea it's a stupid
execution it has stupid characters it's
just this is Pixar I mean
freaking Pixar I mean why didn't you
make the Incredibles to affect why are
you making monsters Inc to The
Incredibles is just sitting there that's
practically made for a sequel you have
other super villains you can have the
kids grow up you can do so much just
really cars was the one that demanded
the story still continued to be told
well unlike the first one I wasn't the
only one that disliked it the critics
didn't like it audiences didn't like it
I don't even think it was that big a hit
at the box office I think it's the first
official dud that Pixar put out that I
think everybody agreed was a waste of
time
which to its credit for the lineup Pixar
had with the successful movies and only
now for it to have one that wasn't a hit
that's pretty impressive but I think
most people can clearly see why it
wasn't a hit it's not a good idea for a
sequel in my opinion wasn't even a good
idea for a first movie the character and
stories don't Worr an interest at the
most it's a bunch of pretty images to
keep your toddler quiet and I don't
think that's what people expect when
they hear the name Pixar I mean it's
nothing like the worst movie I've ever
seen or anything but I didn't see the
point in in existing and I don't think
anyone else did either but hey could
Pixar pull themselves out of the mud and
make a big hit once again next movie
you